we need a few more oh really one more
detail to work out an actual volume here
let's suppose let's suppose i give you
the equation for the circle okay I why'd
you call this circle well just to make
that numbers a little bit convenient
let's call x squared plus y squared
equals 16 so even though where is 3d
business happening this is still an XY
plane okay so that means that intercepts
are 4 4 negative 4 3 4 cool after you
have a question um I was gonna see this
shape would look like a soccer stadium
here cuz of this yeah and some of you've
seen like some of the train stations
we've got the newer translations have
like overhanging sort of hoods that kind
of look like that an onion I know the
new stations if you've seen the designs
for the Norris it's a truck they haven't
put that kind of attackers he's got
those ridges but anyway right how I got
to work out the volume of this thing's
real color just like we've had before
even though there's nothing to do with
rotation I still have an infinite number
of infinitesimally thin things that are
adding on so all I need to do is work
out well what's the volume of it shows
things and then integrate over to
proprio domain so off on the side here
why don't you draw is one of our similar
cross section that is important that
they're all similar to each other
because that means as x and y very right
all these cross sections will basically
follow the same kinds of rooms they will
get bigger and smaller according to save
kinds of quantities so draw for me over
here a square prison that's got a
roughly correspond to this one so
something like this
here's one of my square present and I'm
interested in well what are the
dimensions of this thing okay i'll give
you the easiest one to start because of
the way that I've sliced this across and
constructed this the width of each of my
infinitesimally fear prisons ones along
which access it's the x axis so this is
a delta X D agree with that okay now
when I have a look at these distances
here right keeping in mind that I want
everything in regard to X eventually
eventually right I look and I see okay
well from the center from the center
when I go upwards here right that
corresponds to be going upwards here do
you see that but of course that's just
the y coordinate is it that's the height
there okay so this distance here is why
but I don't actually want that distant
that's only half the distance I want
right I actually want it to be too i
right so the width of this square is 2 y
that make sense but of course it's a
square so that means its height there's
also two one yes so therefore if I label
this thing let's call this area here
this cross section area let's be really
original and call it a the area of this
cross section here is just going to be
2y times 2i which is for wise man okay I
know the cross sectional area it's prism
I know the perpendicular height or the
width whichever way you want to talk
about it so now I ready believe it or
not at all the pieces I need ok I am so
confident I can do it quickly i'm just
going to fit up here ok so i will in a
second right when i put together this
volume ok i have getting limiting
behavior on guitar
x approaches 0 okay now what am i adding
up luckily for us in this case it's very
very convenient in that you can even get
this wrong and you'd still get it right
because it's a circle if you even chose
the wrong boundaries well the chevra
grounders you choose are going to be the
same okay in this case in this case I've
got dr. X right so which values would
you choose negin 424 I think would be
the best choice I will point out this is
also going to clearly be an even
function as well so if you wanted to you
could go from North 24 and then you
could double it that's all fine let's
just keep it this way for what am i
adding up here it's a whole bunch of
prisms nope eyes nope I it's okay no
rotations happening right I've got this
area times this height right so I'm just
going to write that for y squared dot X
ok and now as mark suggested I actually
want to turn this into an integral I
want to turn this into an integral that
y squared I wanted all in terms of X's
right so I look over here every x and y
is on is on the circumference of this
circle right so every exit might follow
is this do you remember when we were
doing that second before you got a bit
confused because there was the court and
then there was the equation of the arc
and you're like well which one is the X
and which one's the way in this case is
unambiguous i'm just going to write y
squared as a subject so i can substitute
it and y squared of course is super easy
right okay let's have we got this let's
turn this into an integral I'm going to
take out the cluster coefficient for
negative 4 24 I'm going to say ok this
is going to be 16 take away x squared DX
and at this point I am going to say
actually know what you can already read
off what the integral of this is right
based on this integrand yeah you're like
island is going to be exodus tough you
know what i should take advantage of the
fact that this is an even function it'll
be a lot easier for me so what am I
going to do to do that
what are you from you have a semicircle
right this is an earring function is it
even function so the integral of an even
function on symmetrical boundaries is
just double a double before from north
to 460 tanking that's going to be a lot
easier isn't it right because you're
going to get back um when you evaluated
that zero boundary all just calm down
okay I'm ready uh what is the integral
what is the primitive 16x okay you've
redeemed yourself 10 now when I've ever
this guy this is very very simple right
you've got your eight at the front okay
this looks to me like c64 takes away 64
on three take away 00 take 1 plus you
look I'll which is that's going to be 12
528 on 3 times 8 which i believe is 1024
on three and it's a volume so where did
it go yeah so what have we established
let me move this down because it's
important and refer to a second just
like before all we have to do it sounds
crazy okay but all we have to do is
think about what kinds of things are you
adding up that's what you need to know
and then work out its volume and then
add up all of the ones that you need to
okay now what makes us a little more
challenging is because unlike um slices
and cylindrical shells right this now
cracks open like this anything anything
you like right so long as you have
similar cross-sections right so the
number of ways you can create volumes
like this becomes much larger will point
out the mass is no harder in fact I'd
argue sometimes the mass is a lot easier
like look at this it's a lot easier than
what you did cylindrical shells in
particular so there's a hard I think it
took where you get we had to do one we
don't integration by parts yesterday
right
lots of different mess here the numbers
tend to be quite easy the hard part is
seeing it and working on that beer okay
and everyone will look quite different